fifty years ago next week Neil Armstrong
became the first man to walk on the moon
the world is engrossed when Armstrong
took his small step for man but giant
leap for mankind
and yet within a decade the u.s. space
program was being decried as a waste of
money in the United States budgets were
slashed but were the critics right back
then I remember watching that first
landing on a small black and white
television and we were all so excited we
all felt we were watching history being
made and we were part of it surely going
where no man has gone before was a great
human adventure worth every penny of the
investment ironically we are now
witnessing a new space faced with China
and India entering the competition with
President Trump like President Kennedy
before him now promising an exciting
future for us space travel according to
him not only will Americans land on the
moon but there will also land on Mars in
the not-too-distant future is this just
typical Trump lavada
or will we really see man back on the
moon within 5 years to say that I'm not
a space enthusiasts is an understatement
I tell ya
so I'm trying from Hollywood Martians in
poured ya know I'm not like I understand
obviously I'm not old enough to have
seen it happen real time so I'd done
it's difficult for me to relate to the
excitement that you felt I do think that
it is for me when I look at go about 50
years it felt authentic it felt like we
were doing something that was real that
we're exploring because we wanted to
educate to learn to discover now I fear
that all of this Moon and Mars
exploration is down to eager it's about
countries racing to be their first
racing to spend more money racing to go
yes it's our country's flag that's going
to be there first and that makes me
slightly
of all it also makes me slightly
uncomfortable and I'm going off to
off-topic slightly and I'm sorry to put
a damper on your excitement but I really
don't think we should be paying and
foreign aid into countries like India
who are very proudly boasting about
their multi-million pound space thing
that they're going to be starting to
program I'm starting to do this year so
now that I've made pod negativity on to
your topic I shall yield for someone
that's let's just have a look these are
iconic pictures let's just have a look
again because Nick is probably one of
the people who believes that it was all
staged at the time it was such an
immense occasion and also I do think
that you know talking about ego actually
Michelle it was about ego this was about
America and Russia and who was gonna win
the space race my only problem with it
my only problem with it no no but it's
but you know it was absolutely necessary
was a great thing much my only problem
with it now though Gregg is for people
like the sort of Elon Musk's and the
Jeff Bezos of this world for them the
sort of modern-day industrialists they
see this as another alternative you know
when all goes were wrong with the world
hey we've got Mars will colonize Mars or
whatever and for me I think you know
what what we know for sure is planet
Earth so let's sort out planet Earth
before we start worrying about space I
can I bring in just one quote than LUT
Carol this is from astronomer royal
martin rees he says there is a tendency
to see Mars as the solution to all our
problems on earth we will just move on
to a new planet and save our species but
that is a dangerous delusion we have to
solve Earth's problems here and now
coping with climate change may seem
daunting but it will be a doddle
compared with surviving on Mars okay but
that's the whole point of space
exploration you can solve those problems
there's medical well let me tell you
there's medical research happening in
space now let's do an earth - well we
can't that's the point we can't well
then why just rent it inside
that's what it says right Melissa it
says it's going to promote life says
Edna also we are speeding through our
natural resources at a rate of spaces we
can never bear we're gonna bring the
resources back here no let me finish
this
so with and Space Exploration you would
not have GPS systems satellites weather
predictions solar cells you wouldn't
have those little blankets that people
wear at the end of marathons you
wouldn't have the ultraviolet must
remember that moment I remember it
vividly I think I would have been 9 or
10 and my late dad was news editing the
Daily Mirror so he helped put together
so I will never forget it but the cost
is extraordinary it's somewhere in the
region and you rightly say Jeff Bezos
yeah Richard Branson but it's going to
be around 200 thousand pounds so as
there's only one member of the panel who
has that sort of money very kindly Greg
has played but you've got to use these
tickets this year so Carol it is the
will of the people but you go Greg I'm
afraid you have to go with Michelle
nevermind hull you're going to space if
you can get it and this will come back
to it's great I just wonder the
challenges and you look at what's
happening and I don't want to become too
right on here but you look at the
challenges that we're slowly suffocating
although less sea life everything like I
wonder whether we should clear out the
oceans before we try and out of
exclusive I get it's a hard it's a hard
ass people are dying of hunger you know
when there's disease everywhere Tran
sorted out here but a lot of what's
going on in space is going to help sort
that are we hold Y Smith my ticket one
way
that's my Bond plot I run the whole
thing okay there's an interesting quote
from the head of Chinese I don't think
it's right for this cracker what he said
was if we don't go there now even though
we're capable of doing so then we will
be blamed by our descendants which i
think is valid point but then he says if
others go there then they will take over
and you won't be able to go even if you
want to this is reason enough now is he
basically saying with Chinese if they
get to certain planets I'm thinking let
anybody land they can be international I
can't believe great guy tell you what
we'll be blamed by descendants for is if
we let our earth go to pot so let's saw
our planet Earth yes then tremendous
also sustained which cannabis was in
that case you see you're gonna kill the
seas across it I'm not entirely across I
won't listen the new chairman of Virgin
Galactic he says people want to go there
and they have to Donald Trump who has
coffee won all there I'm thrilled to
sign a new order taking the next step to
create the United States space force so
important when you look at the fence
when you look at all of the other
aspects of where the world will be
someday I mean this is the beginning of
a very important process that's gonna be
a very big part of where the defense of
our nation and you could say offense but
let's just be nice about it let's say
the defense of our nation is going to be
now I'm willing to give my ticket
actually I'll give them two tickets I
will give
wonder him and one two boys cuz they're
both they're both one one I love that
this is the beginning that according to
trauma let's see where it ends there
well I suspect he's position about
defense is quite is quite forward yeah
you know I said the Americans are
terrified of the Chinese it ends right
here soon copy you there Nick so now
from one type of moon walking to another
and scientists from the US revealed a
new study this week that left abba
questioning if they really had found
their dancing queen snowballs the
cockatoo broke the internet back in 2007
for his performance of the Backstreet
Boys the song everybody and after a
decade of studying his steps scientists
now think this bevery freestyler proves
dancing isn't just limited to humans
despite never taking lessons snowball
has acquired fourteen distinct moves
which he gets out as soon as he hears a
funky beat let's take a look so it's not
just girls who wanna have fun snowball
for that headbanger alone you are are
smooth mover of the week so couple
battle corners before you do that I
wanna see who's got the move let's see
usually bait this mother clucker
Michelle
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you've been doing for the last two you
that sir on skype a this week and I was
told it was a stupid story I shouldn't
have done it well there we go